HAVING ME.
I WOKE UP FOR SOME REASON, I
COULDN'T SLEEP.
I WOKE UP.
I SAW A LOT OF TEXTS ON MY
PHONE.
I SAW THE NEWS.
I CRIED OUT OF JOY.
I THANKED GOD.
I DON'T KNOW.
I WAS OVERWHELMED.
WE'VE BEEN ASKING FOR
PROTECTION.
CONSEQUENCES FOR MORE THAN SIX
YEARS AND TODAY FOR THE FIRST
TIME IT HAPPENED, FOR THE VERY
FIRST TIME WE SEE ASSAD HELD
ACCOUNTABLE JUST FOR ONCE, HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR HIS CRIMES
AGAINST HUMANITY.
I WAS OVERWHELMED.
I FELT GRATEFUL FOR PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
I FELT GRATEFUL FOR THE UNITED
STATES.
I FELT GRATEFUL FOR EACH AND
EVERY UP THAT
INITIAL CHEMICAL ATTACK, BUT
THERE ARE PEOPLE IN AMERICA AND
I HEAR YOU SUPPORTIVE OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND SO MANY
PEOPLE ARE, DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS, BUT THERE ARE ALSO
PEOPLE OVER HERE IN AMERICA
SAYING ALL RIGHT, CLEARLY
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS MOTIVATED AS
WE ALL HAVE COMPASSION FOR THESE
JUST HORRIBLE IMAGES OF, YOU
KNOW, THESE BABIES WHO WERE
KILLED, BUT AT THE SAME TIME
THIS IS A MAN WHO, YOU KNOW,
DOESN'T WANT SYRIANS TO COME
INTO THIS COUNTRY WITH THIS
REFUGEE BAN.
LET ME JUST PLAY SOME SOUND.
HILLARY CLINTON WEIGHED IN.
>> WE CANNOT IN ONE BREATH SPEAK
OF PROTECTING SYRIAN BABIES AND
IN THE NEXT CLOSE AMERICA'S
DOORS TO THEM.
>> QUICKLY, KASSAM, HOW DO YOU
SEE THAT?
>> WITH ALL DUE RESPECT, WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT, I DIDN'T SEE
EACH AND EVERY PERSON WHO WAS
DEMONSTRATING AFTER THE TRAVEL
BAN.
I DIDN'T SEE YOU THREE DAYS AGO
WHEN PEOPLE WERE GASSED TO
DEATH, WHEN CIVILIANS WERE
GASSED TO DEATH.
I DIDN'T SEE YOU IN 2013 WHEN
1,400 PEOPLE WERE GASSED TO
DEATH.
I DIDN'T SEE YOU RAISING YOUR
VOICE AGAINST PRESIDENT OBAMA'S
INACTION IN SYRIA THAT LED US
REFUGEES, THAT MADE US REFUGEES
GET KICKED OUT OF SYRIA.
IF YOU REALLY CARE ABOUT
REFUGEES, IF YOU REALLY CARE
ABOUT HELPING US, PLEASE, HELP
US STAY IN OUR -- IN OUR
COUNTRY.
WE DON'T WANT TO COME TO UNITED
STATES.
WE WANT TO STAY IN OUR COUNTRY,
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT.
THIS IS HYPOCRISY.
IF YOU REALLY CARE, IF YOU
REALLY CARE, HELP US STAY IN OUR
COUNTRY.
WE DON'T WANT TO BECOME
REFUGEES.
WE WANT TO STAY IN OUR COUNTRY.
HELP US ESTABLISH SAFE ZONES.
>> UNDERSTAND.
>> HELP US STAY IN OUR COUNTRY,
AND IF YOU JUST GIVE ME A FEW
SECONDS JUST TO TELL PRESIDENT
TRUMP ONCE AGAIN, PLEASE, SIR,
WHAT YOU DID WAS AMAZING, WHAT
YOU DID WAS POWERFUL MESSAGE OF
HOPE FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE INSIDE
AND OUTSIDE OF SYRIA.
PLEASE, DON'T STOP ON THIS.
PLEASE, HELP SYRIANS STAY IN
THEIR COUNTRY.
PLEASE ESTABLISH SAFE ZONES AND
PLEASE TAKE OUT ASSAD OWES AIR
FORCE SO THEY WON'T BE ABLE TO
COMMIT MORE ATROCITIES
COMMITTING